Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie. We just got a first look at JessicaJones Daredevil Born Again they're getting ready
to film the series so we'll break it all down
because they are bringing back pretty much all
the Netflix Defenders characters eventually it's
just that Jessica Jones is like one of the next
big ones that they're introducing if you're brand
new to the channel of course I'll be doing videos
for all the episodes they'll be filming this
series for pretty much all this year so we'll
get a bunch more footage from the series soon we
also have a big Ant-Man of the WASP Quantum Mania
trailer video for the movies that's going to be
dropping really soon I'll be doing videos for that
too but you may have seen your feeds blowing up
the last couple of days because Kristen Ritter's
Jessica Jones coming back to the MCU for Daredevil
Born Again season one you can see her wearing a
daredevil Born Again t-shirt here the logo is
the exact same as the new MCU version the logo
that Kevin feige just debuted at d23 at the big
Daredevil panel supposed to talk about my show
where your shirt I think you made my show
Daredevil born again my name is Jessica the funny
thing about that is they were both there for the
echo panel for the echo episodes and they just
stayed for the Daredevil Born Again episodes
I'll explain what's happening during Echo soon too
because there's a big Daredevil Kingpin storyline
during that but they were just joking about whose
show Daredevil born again would be like Daredevil
is in the title you'd think it's about him so
Charlie Cox is like what do you talk about my
show but obviously Vincent donoprio just joking
the Kingpin is going to believe that it's his show
it's all about him the reason why you're seeing
Kristen Ritter getting ready for Daredevil born
again is because they start filming next month
like I said they're doing 18 episodes in season
one meaning they will be filming for pretty
much the entire year it was supposed to start
releasing episodes at the beginning of 2024 but
because they delayed Echo to the beginning of 2024
they might have pushed Daredevil born again just
like a little bit after that but you get the idea
it's coming right after the echo episodes because
that's the way the story is playing out according
to reports Marvel also had a plan to bring Kristen
Ritter back as Jessica Jones before this during
the She-Hulk episodes which makes sense because
because her day job is a paralegal so you'd expect
her Jennifer Walters Matt Murdoch to cross pass
in the normal courses of their jobs outside the
being Vigilantes it was the whole basis for
Daredevil's Cameo on She-Hulk he was in LA as
Matt Murdoch first as a lawyer they had a teaser
while he was there for his new Daredevil suits as
well too like it turns out that he's getting his
new suits from this person in La now Luke Jacobson
made a couple of new suits for me so I owe him one
doesn't really look like him like it it's a low
blow insulting a blind man's clothes the new suits
that he references there are suits that he'll wear
in the future on the echo series and Daredevil
board again like there are a couple other suits
that were made for him that we didn't see because
we won't see them until Echo and Daredevil born
again all the new ones are meant to be versions of
his comic book suits like the yellow one was based
on his very first red and yellow suit from his
first Comics appearance that was why they had all
the jokes about it on the series about it looking
like ketchup and mustard like why would you wear
such clashing colors like wouldn't you want to not
stand out in the battle he was wearing it because
it was his first comic book suit and obviously
like a lot of the logic in those classic Comics is
really jokey is that I couldn't figure out who it
was and I realized it was it was the new Daredevil
suit and they've Incorporated the the gold or
the yellow from some of the earlier Daredevil
Comics he'll also have a version of his classic
red suit reimagined like a brand new version of
the red suit not the same one that he wore during
Daredevil Netflix he'll also have a version of his
newer black suit not the classic one from the
Daredevil Netflix series like the Lo-Fi black
suit the new one would be like the Back in Black
costume which is just a little bit different like
an upgraded Black costume he might have more suits
than that but those are just the ones that we know
about right now the story for Jessica Jones and
the MCU probably hasn't changed that much even
though they've moved around some of the series and
they got rid of our Cameo scenes during She-Hulk
I believe the reason she wasn't on She-Hulk was
because she was busy filming another series at
the time and wasn't available to do those episodes
but during the echo episodes there's supposed to
be a bunch of Daredevil and Kingpin because of
kingpin's relationship with Echo he's meant to
be one of the main villains of that series too
but in a much bigger way than he was during the
Hawkeye series like during Hawkeye was a pretty
short Cameo and even though there was a little bit
more of Daredevil during the She-Hulk episodes
that was still just a smaller Cameo they're
supposed to be more of them more scenes for them
in the Echo series and it'll be the first time
that Daredevil and Kingpin are in the same series
like in the same production together in the MCU
even though canonically they are treating the
characters almost as the same versions from the
Netflix series they're picking and choosing what
parts of the Canon they bring forward from the
Netflix series but for the most part the series is
supposed to be Canon but according to Charlie Cox
they're reimagining some aspects from the show
so like not every single little thing is going
to be something they carry forward really good
example that's why the yellow suit on She-Hulk
looked almost exactly the same as the classic
red suit on the Netflix series just to show you
that most of that stuff was Canon during the echo
episodes the story for Jessica Jones is supposed
to be that she's missing in Daredevils looking
for her aside from the main story of echo versus
Kingpin and Daredevil vs Kingpin going on so while
they're all busy in the background Daredevil is
still looking for Jessica Jones the whole idea
with Kingpin is that didn't kill him at the end
of Hawkeye they just made it seem that way this
ending scene is just right out of the comics her
backstory on the series is similar to the comics
version she's from the Daredevil Comics like a
lot of the She-Hulk villains most of those smaller
funny villains were either like Daredevil villains
or Punisher villains because they're bringing so
many of the Netflix characters into the MCU in a
much more proper way Kingpin raised Ekko to be his
weapon lied to her saying the Daredevil killed her
father so that she'd be more effective in trying
to get rid of him for Kingpin then secretly as
we saw in Hawkeye it was Kingpin who killed her
father betraying her so they just did a version
of that on the Hawkeye series she shoots him in
Revenge the same way but only winds up blinding
him and when he returns is meant to be this ironic
twist because he's blind just like Daredevil for a
little while but eventually he gets his sight back
the whole thing with the echo series is supposed
to explore some special powers and mythology that
they teased during her bedtime story with her
father like they talk about this crazy magic the
story that he tells her supposedly that's going
to turn into like a real thing during the echo
series it will be that stuff weaved with regular
crime Thriller because you have Daredevil Kingpin
characters Jessica Jones might have a cameo scene
in Echo I don't think she's supposed to but
it's always possible if they change some of
that because they've shuffled the series around
a little bit there have been a couple of delays
I think because they want to polish some stuff but
he is supposed to find her during Daredevil born
again and she's a bigger part of the plot during
that series like the way that you would expect her
when they say that she's going to be a big part of
the series the way that Charlie Cox talked about
the episodes he said that Daredevil born again
would be just like the tone and the vibe of the
Netflix series but because they had so many extra
episodes they'd be doing way more courtroom scenes
like you saw during Daredevil season 2 when he was
defending the Punisher who will also probably come
back in the MCU at some point I know I mentioned
the Punisher people like when are they going to
bring Frank Castle Punisher back they're not going
to recast the role like Kevin feige isn't planning
on recasting Punisher but I don't know if they
have plans to use him during Daredevil season 1.
there are 18 episodes so obviously there's like
a lot of Cameo spots they could use for people
the other Netflix Defenders character said that
they love to come back it's just a question of
available ability in what room they have for them
in the story like what are they already doing like
Luke Cage Colleen Wing even Finn Jones said he
wanted to come back as Iron Fist you probably saw
that recently too some news articles about Iron
Fist wanting to prove people wrong that he would
come back in the MCU we'll see about that I really
wasn't a fan of what they did with the character
so I'm totally fine with them just waiting to
use him for years or just completely recasting
the Iron Fist role in the MCU my actual MCU
Iron Fist idea is for them to just do something
completely separate with him and use him as one
of the villains of the shung Shi series because
he's supposed to be a hero but because shangshi's
people Worship the Great protector dragon in tah
low in iron fist gets his powers from killing a
cosmic dragon they should just say that MCU Iron
Fist winds up killing the great protector dragon
as part of his origin story instead of the concept
of the capital cities of Heaven Khan Lund their
Celestial configuration the tournament of heaven
interesting that they exist in the same alternate
Dimension that talo does and they can use the Iron
Fist mythology in in the tournament of Heaven to
do a really badass shangshi tournament Arc for the
character like classic Bruce Lee Enter the Dragon
which they kind of use as inspiration for some of
the first shangshi movie like we all want to see
shangshi get a much cooler tournament Arc the Iron
Fist Tournament of Heaven in the capital cities
of Heaven would be the way to do that then they
can just fold iron fist into more ground level
Daredevil street level stuff in the MCU the bigger
storyline they're supposed to be doing during
Daredevil Born Again season 1 is Mayor Kingpin
like the whole idea in Marvel phase five just in
general through all the movies all the series is
they're going with a very dark Reign inspired
overarching story spinning at a secret Invasion
where the antagonists take control in positions
of power Thunderbolt Ross is supposed to become
president of the United States around the same
time like in Captain America 4 New World Order
which is being released right around the same
time that Daredevil born again is being released
Val's already become director of the CIA now
wielding enormous power which she's going to use
to create the Thunderbolts and it all spins out
of what happens with the evil Scrolls in secret
invasion in the whole idea is that the villains
the antagonists start taking credit for getting
rid of them in writing that wave of popularity to
even greater political power kingpin's story is
just localized to New York City with him basically
taking control of New York City riding that wave
and turning it into something more akin to a
police state like doing really terrible stuff
in the light of day and people loving him for
it because of what happened with the Scrolls
like look see if we're not this hardcore then the
scrolls are going to take over the planet again
and Daredevil trying to be a hero amidst all that
they kind of started to do that during Daredevil
season 3 where Kingpin took this position to
power like the public started to love him he
was kind of lying about what he was doing though
eventually Daredevil won out by making people
see him for what he really was so they're kind of
doing a larger version of that like a much bigger
version during Marvel phase five but everyone let
me know in the comments what do you want them to
do with the other Netflix Defenders characters it
sounds like we'll see them in addition to Jessica
Jones in the next few years like I said there's
a brand new Ant-Man the Wasp Quantumania trailer
video coming in the next couple of days be sure
to enable alerts for my channel so you don't miss
that of course I'll do videos for everything click
here for that brand new trailer I'll update the
link as soon as I post that and click here for my
new Deadpool 3 Hugh Jackman versus Ryan Reynolds
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one.